hey leute herzlich willkommen zum
heutigen video titel 10 challenges in
einem video der volkswirt beats and
exchange allerdings habe ich dir zuletzt
mit luca auf seinem kanal gemacht da
hätten wir aber mein video verloren
gegangen und luca ist jetzt in berlin
und leipzig einfach nur ich wollte dabei
nach oben erst mal sagen wir sind in
meiner neuen wohnung noch vor kurzem
ansichten sondern mit luka pavic an die
wand gemalt
es gibt sicherlich aber heute machen wir
erstmal die change ich würde sagen wir
reden kein rummel gelegen so sind drei
zwar immer ein ganzes was du machst mich
schützen und 14
älterwerden nicht machen wir einfach von
überfälliger weg bild.de
leute wir machen das ganze heute
übrigens nicht irgendwie dann wir machen
mit einer bestrafung wir haben so eine
scharfe worte und machen dann noch
pfeffer und wann verbreiten der
verlierer muss davon ein café retten
die vorher gerade natürlich nicht gleich
wasser also wirklich schlecht
es ist eine befreiung
[Musik]
der gerissene haake frage aber kampf mit
sicherheit sagen dass nicht julia blutig
oder sowas in der zwischenzeit wieder
locker wie das körbchen aktivitäten
online special
auch wirklich etwas auf dem tisch liegen
blocken papier malen sie weg und
erkennbar einen deutschen sieg
[Musik]
ich bin schockiert dass diese
erkenntnisse müssen dass leute die seit
der ganz viele kunden drehten longboard
weiter verbessert lag schon 1 kor aber
es bleibt spannend
da verliert man kommt die aufgabe
mietrecht umdenken zu machen alle dürfen
sich jetzt nur fünfmal das spiel denke
immer an lässt wäre besser für mich die
tennis meister fk wird die verpflanzung
wieder auf wachstum und her
[Musik]
ich finde wenn man zeitig auf den
richtigen macgyver live machen hat das
nur mit den links angefahren kann beugt
euch dann auch kaputt wenn du kannst
halt nicht bis heute schon sagen dass
die schlachter
das wäre sehr korrekt aber dann hat
machen wir sicher gehalten werden wir
kunden melden ihre politiker
[Musik]
obwohl die einfachen sachen halt voll
okay geht gar nicht möglich war die
aufgabe wachsen das hat für mich ja
schon markiert weiter video punkt einen
jungen catherine 3 millionen und auf der
man verdammt bedingungen auf 1 million
können
für die gegner weiter
[Musik]
33 die früchte die mitte und ich glaube
ich weiß nicht ob die ware superstars
ich koche ja klar mit limetten und ja
natürlich aber trotzdem lukas die krone
und papaya dann mag meine frau hübner
statische anstrengend oder fleißige
röcken betreten
sieben sekunden machten ja
[Musik]
das recht gebrochen führen
man muss sagen das war ja immer auch
hälfte vermutlich heute gemütlich muss
man sagen aber glaub ich ja für
frischkäse ehrlich wirklich vor ort ein
problem hab ich hab meine aufgabe gern
problem ist egal hier auch also
eigentlich schon ja wird ab dem aufwind
für das geht ab dann einfach nach
ich bin ja leute schreibt man wenn ihr
jetzt noch dran sei challenge in die
kommentare einfach wird das habe ich
nicht gehört für wenn die sache noch in
[Musik]
35 staaten der usa vertreten
die 44 los angeles erschienen die viel
fehlt ja ich hab jetzt sagen ja
[Musik]
logischerweise gibt
aber dafür ist eine chili note so eine
süß scharfe soße und wir haben immer ich
bestraft erweitert wir verfeinern das
ganze mit fetter und vertrittst du davon
zubereiten würde ich sagen
[Musik]
13.000 gleich